le jeune peintre orléanais alexandre
tyjnia n'a que 22 ans lorsqu'il envoie
au salon de 1849
un grand tableau après le bain qui voile
imposé parmi les grands noms de son
époque alors tout de suite la ville
d'orléans souhaite acquérir ce tableau
pour son musée pour représenter ce grand
enfant du pays l'arrivée se fait dans le
plus grand des scandales à peine arrivé
le tableau en 1850 déchaîne la passion
des orléanais qui s'offusque de voir des
ces corps nu et lascif de femmes qui ne
sont ni des ds need et orientale mais
bien des contemporaine posant nue pour
le peindre
[Musique]
l'afer est portée devant le maire qui
regrette un petit peu cet achat demande
qu'un voile pudique soient placés au
pastel par le conservateur sur les
parties intimes des des jeunes femmes
le peintre s'offusque porte la faire
devant l'administration impériale le
compte de nokere que s'en empare et la
presse nationale s'empare de ce sujet
absolument délicieux et fait ses gorges
chaudes de la pudibonderie des orléanais
qui restera assez célèbre jusqu'à la
rétrospective antilla au xxème siècle où
seulement le tableau a été restaurée et
où l'on a retiré les repeints